on va en parler tout de suite avec notre
prochaine invité sébastien st louis qui
pdg et co fondateur du producteur
québécois de cannabis exo bonsoir
bonsoir votre réaction d'abord à la
transaction d'aujourd'hui entre ifria
hétéro et toujours réaction quand même
un petit peu inévitable dans le sens que
la consolidation dans l'industrie va se
passer va continuer de se développer
il ya au dessus de 500 producteurs dans
le marché canadien aujourd'hui
et puis quand on regarde les ports de
marché ils disent des producteurs qui
détiennent 90% des parts de marché et
puis typiquement en produits
consommateurs on voit trop aux
producteurs un typiquement contrôle et
70% des ports de marche et c'est qu'ils
aient droit comme celle là on est très
fiers chez xo on est maintenant donc les
quatrièmes donc on a besoin de parts de
marché que on est plus de parts de
marché que théorique comme celle a
évidemment avec la fusion entre lui et
atrium vont est en première place
temporairement mais on travaille fort là
dessus se le dise ça s'est pas passé
comme prévu depuis deux ans pour le
secteur du cannabis il beaucoup de mises
à pied de restructuration là on voit une
consolidation qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui se passe en ce moment mais
je pense que vous réalisez camp en deux
ans on établit une industrie légale avec
un chiffre d'affaires de 3 milliards de
dollars et donc quand même un grand
succès de ce point de la caq on
considère qu'on a déjà pénétré entre 30
et 40% du marché noir donc un grand
succès pour la sûreté publique
du côté affaires c'est certain coûte
c'est tout du nouveau et non seulement
on se lance dans une nouvelle industrie
on se lance même dans des nouveaux
produits donc chaque jour par exemple
avec mon chum course on a lancé du
jamais vu au niveau mondial avec toute
une série de breuvage au cannabis pour
lesquels on vient prendre un premier
report de marché au canada
vous avez cela dit au fil du temps qui
les deux dernières années n'ont pas été
de tout repos justement dans ce
processus la supprimer des emplois il y
a un an vous avez émis des actions chez
exo à la fin de 2019 et vous avez dû
regrouper des actions pour vous
maintenir à la cote
bourse de new york aussi récemment et
votre action a chuté depuis un an et
demi
alors qu'est ce qui se passe pour exo je
pense que regarder c'est vrai que c'est
incroyablement volatile et encore un
secteur à risque et puis si on regarde
en quelques années veut dire on a créé
de la valeur dans les milliards de
dollars et donc la chute de ces hausses
là c'est certain qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé dans le système comme
celle là on arrive finalement dans notre
dernier carré etc sont donc c'est le
premier corps depuis quelques uns
quelques années où ce qui est pas une
une action des mises aussi on voit
passer dans un an d'une perte que ce
constat vraiment un investissement
une perte de 40 millions de dollars l'an
passé à une carte de 400 mille dollars
ou donnez vous voyez on ferme la boucle
et puis on est sur le seuil de devenir
profitable et au sein d'une nouvelle
industrie vous prévoyez ces exodes être
profitable en 2021
on va être profitable devrait bientôt on
a mentionné des portables sur une base
ibdaa donc avant amortissement donc dans
nos deux plus jeunes car qui se termine
en janvier
et puis quand on compare devrait
profitabilité mais ça ça va venir
rapidement par la suite
est ce que le nerf de la guerre pour
vous comme pour les autres c'est le
marché américain qui s'ouvre non c'est
certain que le marché américain est
super intéressant et puis justement
vendredi on s'est lancé avec mons une
course dans note d'un partenariat on a
lancé des breuvages aux cbd au colorado
au nôtre ça c'est quelque chose faut le
dire l'innovation québécoise lancée avec
une des plus grosses compagnies au monde
mohssen aux états unis après prendra
part de marché dans un marché cannabis
légal donc ça super excitant puis oui ça
donne tout une envergure où ça pourrait
aller dans le futur d'ailleurs d'où
viens je pense que les évaluations qui
était très très haut par le passé ça
vient de ses attentes
malgré quand on regarde le marché
canadien si on considère lors 3
milliards de dollars si le marché se
développe à dison 7 à 10 milliards de
dollars
des producteurs aux hôtes nous on fait
notre tombe et d'à peu près 42 cents par
dollar donc si on allait chercher comme
industrie les producteurs dont 1,4
milliard
les trois producteurs à la file à la
tête de tueur et puis je vous rappelle
que l'ex haut et court à la numéro 4
mais les producteurs qui vont être à la
tête de ça ça va crier de l'énorme
valeur et puis ça continue évidemment de
créer beaucoup d'emplois ici au québec
est-ce que vous explorez toujours la
possibilité d'avoir un partenaire ou
même un acquéreur dont pour exxon notre
stratégie c'est vraiment d'investir dans
la technologie du cannabis puis de créer
des expériences uniques à partir des
molécules qui s'y trouvent
par la suite on veut avoir plusieurs
partenaires notre premier derrière ses
murs une course par laquelle on serait
au marché dont vous verriez dans le
futur que aix on pourrait rajouter des
partenaires que ce soit dans
l'alimentation ou dans les produits de
santé pour insérer notre technologie
donc par usb haxo pour ensuite aller
dans les marchés outre-mer on a zéro
intention de vendre comme celle-là on
pense qu'on a beaucoup de valeur à des
cultes et dans les médias par fait très
bien sébastien st louis et merci
beaucoup
alors ça vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh